[Musique]
la circulation épidémique en baisse en
ile-de-france conséquence un protocole
sanitaire allégée par le gouvernement
fin de l'obligation du port du masque en
extérieur ou encore faim des jauges pour
les établissements recevant du public
assis le programme c'était de l'emploi
de saint quentin en yvelines a été
officiellement lancée le but renforcer
l'accès à l'emploi et à la formation aux
habitants des quartiers prioritaires
objectif mieux coordonner les
dispositifs déjà présents sur le
territoire côté sport après sa victoire
contre toulouse le fc versailles
affrontera bergerac en quart de finale
de coupe de france un record historique
pour le club amateur versailles et le
match se déroulera à périgueux coup
d'envoi mercredi 9 février à 18h30 la
facture s'alourdit pour le projet eole
1,7 milliard d'euros supplémentaires
nécessaires au prolongement du rer e
dont les yvelines une enquête a été
ouverte par le conseil régional
d'ile-de-france en politique jordan par
dell a été mis en examen le député
européen pour le rassemblement national
avait qualifié la ville de trappes de
république islamique
des propos tenus en octobre dernier
suite à la réélection du maire à lire à
b et puis elle met à l'honneur la ville
des impressionnistes de presse que
réalise à chatou cet été ont été
présélectionnés pour les golden street a
lancé par trompe-l'oeil info le concours
récompense les plus belles presque de
france